this first one you can see that it's in
vertex form now remember vertex form is
like this a X minus H squared plus K H
and K that's the vertex of the parabola
the a tells you whether its opening up
if it's positive down if it's negative
and if it's greater than one it's a
stretch and if it's less than 1 or
between 0 and 1 it's a compression right
so let's graph this so it's easy it
looks like the vertex is at positive 2
positive 4 so that's 1 2 3 4 right about
there that's your vertex and then the
negative 2 what we can do is we can make
a table just looking at the parent
function negative 2 x squared
ok you can see that if X is 1 Y is
negative 2 if X is 2 that's going to be
at negative 8 ok so if we plot those
points from the vertex as if it was the
origin we're gonna go right 1 okay and
we're gonna go down 2 so that looks like
it's gonna be right about there and the
same thing over here we're gonna go left
1 down 2 because it's symmetric about
that axis of symmetry gave out the
vertex and then we can plot this point
but it's starting to go off the graph
here so the next thing I'm to do is I'm
just gonna graph it but notice how that
it's less than or equal to and equal to
means it includes the points ok on the
okay I probably should have drawn a few
more points but basically there is a
graph right there it includes the points
on the graph less than or equal to means
that if we pick any point on the graph
let's say like for example the vertex
last thing means we're shading down okay
if it was greater than we're shading out
because remember Y the Y controls the
vertical Direction up and down right so
less than we're shading below so I
picked this point in the graph less than
would be below this point lessons below
less than below so if we can kind of
sketch this a little bit here to get an
idea of that region meaning any point in
this region we'll make this inequality
true any region outside here we'll make
it false now if we want to graph this
second inequality you can see that this
is a quadratic but it's in the factored
form or also known as the intercept form
if we set these factors to 0 we get 2 &
4 okay so let's see we've got one two so
right there and three four right there
okay and if you find the halfway point
between 2 & 4 that's 3 that's going to
be the axis of symmetry of the parabola
and if we put 3 in here you get 3 minus
2 is 1 3 minus 4 here is
a negative 1 1 times negative 1 is
negative 1 so on that axis of symmetry
we're down here at negative 1 now notice
how it's Y is greater than but not equal
to that means this is actually gonna be
a dashed or a dotted graph it doesn't
include the points on the parabola ok it
just includes the points that are
greater than now when you think of
greater than Y again controls the
vertical direction up and down greater
than we're shading above okay so if I
pick any point on this parabola shading
above ok notice I'm shading up like this
and if you can take a closer look here
you can see where are they overlapping
they're overlapping in this region right
here that's where it's crosshatch so I'm
just gonna go back and I'm going to
darken that in a little bit darker so we
can see it so you can see one parabolas
opening up and we're shading greater
than the other ones opening down and
we're shading less and below you don't
want to get in caught where some
students think like inside and outside
don't think that way just think of this
is your parabola greater than pick any
point shade straight up that's what the
Y's by itself that means the Y values
are greater if it's less than then you
would pick a point on the graph and you
would shade below okay like that so
don't think inside outside think above
below and then you see where the two
regions overlap and that's going to be
the solution set any point in here will
make both of these inequalities true and
you've got it so I'm going to do another
video like this if you want to should
see another example example number two
subscribe to the channel check out some
of the other math videos I have on
Mario's math tutor YouTube channel and I
look forward to seeing the future videos
I'll talk to you soon